grouillante de vie,
grouillante de plantes et d'animaux ?
Bien, en un mot, la photosynthèse.
Il y a environ 2 milliards et demi d'années,
certains ancêtres du Prochlorococcus ont évolué
afin de pouvoir utiliser l'énergie solaire,
de l'absorber
et d'instiller de l'eau dans ses parties composées d'oxygène et d'hydrogène.
Puis ils ont utilisé l'énergie chimique produite
pour attirer le CO2, le dioxyde de carbone, hors de l'atmosphère
et l'utiliser pour constituer des sucres, des protéines et des acides aminés,
toutes les choses qui constituent la vie.
Et, au fil de leur évolution, de leur croissance,
durant des millions et des millions d'années,
cet oxygène s'est accumulé dans l'atmosphère.
Jusqu'à il y a environ 500 millions d'années,
il y en avait assez dans l'atmosphère pour que de plus gros organismes évoluent.
Il y a eu une explosion des formes de vie
et nous sommes finalement apparus.
Pendant ce temps,
certains de ces anciens photosynthétiseurs sont morts,
ont été compressés et enterrés
puis se sont transformés en énergie fossile
avec des rayons de soleil emprisonnés dans leurs liens de carbone.
Ils ont enterré des rayons de soleil sous forme de pétrole et de charbon.
Les photosynthétiseurs actuels
ont des moteurs qui proviennent de ces anciens microbes
et ils nourrissent toutes les formes de vie sur Terre.
Votre cœur bat grâce à l'énergie solaire
qu'une plante a traitée pour vous
et les matières qui composent votre corps
se composent du CO2
qu'une plante a traité pour vous.
Nous sommes tous faits de rayons de soleil et de dioxyde de carbone.
De fait, nous sommes de l'air chaud.
(Rires)
Donc, en tant qu'êtres terrestres,
nous connaissons bien les plantes terrestres :
les arbres, les herbes, les pâturages, les cultures.
Mais les océans sont pleins de milliards de tonnes d'animaux.
Ne vous êtes-vous jamais demandé de quoi ils se nourrissaient ?
Il existe un pâturage invisible
de photosynthétiseurs microscopiques appelés phytoplanctons
qui remplissent la partie supérieure de l'océan sur 200 mètres
et ils nourrissent tout l'écosystème de l'océan.
Certains animaux vivent parmi eux et les mangent,
d'autres remontent vers eux pour s'en nourrir la nuit
et d'autres restent au fond de l'océan et attendent qu'ils meurent et tombent
pour se ruer dessus.
Donc, ces minuscules phytoplanctons,
pèsent ensemble moins de 1% du poids de toutes les plantes sur Terre,
mais chaque année, ils photosynthétisent autant que toutes ces plantes,
forêt amazonienne incluse
que l'on considère comme le poumon de la planète.
Chaque année, ils conservent 50 milliards de tonnes de carbone
sous la forme de dioxyde de carbone
dans leur corps qui nourrit l'écosystème de l'océan.
Comment est-ce que cette minuscule quantité de biomasse
réussit à créer autant que toutes les plantes terrestres ?
Elles n'ont ni tronc, ni tiges,
ni fleur, ni fruit, ni rien à entretenir.
Elles n'ont qu'à grandir et se diviser encore et encore.
Ce sont des machines à photosynthèse qui ne consomment rien.
Ils n'arrêtent jamais.
Il y a des milliers de différentes sortes de phytoplancton,
de différentes formes et tailles,
tous à peine moins larges qu'un cheveu humain.
Voici quelques-uns des plus beaux
dans leur version parfaite.
Je les appelle les espèces charismatiques de phytoplancton.
Et voici le Prochlorococcus.
Je sais,
cela ressemble à un tas de saletés sur une languette de microscope.
(Rires)
Mais ils sont là-dedans
et je vais vous les montrer dans quelques instants.
Mais d'abord, je veux vous dire comment ils ont été découverts.
Il y a à peu près 38 ans,
nous faisions des expériences avec une technologie appelée cytométrie en flux
développée pour la recherche biomédicale, pour étudier les cellules cancéreuses,
mais nous l'avons finalement utilisée pour d'autres usages officieux
notamment pour étudier les phytoplanctons, ce qui convenait parfaitement.
Voilà comment ça fonctionne :
on injecte un échantillon dans ce tube capillaire très fin
et les cellules sont séparées par laser,
ce faisant, elles diffractent la lumière selon leur taille
et émettent de la lumière selon leurs différents pigments,
qu'elles soient naturelles ou qu'on les ait colorées.
Et la chlorophylle du phytoplancton,
qui est verte,
émet une lumière rouge quand on l'éclaire d'une lumière bleue.
Nous avons utilisé cet instrument pendant plusieurs années
pour étudier nos cultures de phytoplanctons,
des espèces comme les charismatiques que je vous ai montrés,
en étudiant juste la biologie basique de leurs cellules.
Pendant ce temps, on se disait que ce serait vraiment bien
d'apporter un tel instrument sur un bateau,
de l'arroser d'eau de mer
et de voir à quoi ressemblerait toute cette diversité de phytoplanctons.
Alors, j'ai mis la main
sur ce que l'on appelle un grand gréement en cytométrie en flux,
un laser énorme et puissant.
L'entreprise garantissait le remboursement
et la reprise au cas où il ne fonctionne pas en mer.
Un jeune scientifique avec qui je travaillais à ce moment-là,
Rob Olson, était capable de le démonter,
le mettre sur un bateau, le remonter et l'emporter en mer.
Et ça a très bien fonctionné.
On ne pensait pas que ça marcherait, à cause des vibrations du bateau
qui gêneraient la mise au point du laser
mais ça a vraiment bien fonctionné.
Nous avons cartographié la répartition du phytoplancton dans l'océan.
Pour la première fois, on pouvait observer chaque cellule en temps réel
et voir ce qu'il se passait -- c'était très exaltant.
Mais un jour, Rob a remarqué quelques signaux faibles
émis par l'instrument
que nous avions pris pour du bruit électronique
pendant à peu près un an
avant de réaliser que ça ne se comportait pas vraiment comme du bruit.
Cela prenait une forme régulière.
En bref,
il y avait de minuscules cellules,
moins d'un centième de la largeur d'un cheveu humain
qui contenaient de la chlorophylle.
C'était les Prochlorococcus.
Vous vous souvenez de la diapositive que je vous ai montrée ?
Si vous éclairez cet échantillon avec de la lumière bleue,
voici ce que vous pourrez voir :
deux minuscules cellules émettant de la lumière rouge.
Ce sont des Prochlorococcus.
Les cellules photosynthétiques les plus petites sur la planète.
Au début, on ignorait ce qu'elles étaient,
on les baptisa donc « petits verts ».
C'était un petit nom très affectueux.
Puis nous en avons assez appris pour leur donner le nom de Prochlorococcus,
ce qui signifie « baie verte primitive ».
Et c'était à ce moment-là
que je me suis tellement entichée de ces petites cellules
que j'ai réorienté tout mon laboratoire pour ne plus étudier qu'elles
et ma loyauté a été récompensée.
Elles m'ont énormément apporté, y compris cette conférence.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Au cours des années, nous et d'autres, beaucoup d'autres,
avons étudié les Prochlorococcus à travers les océans
et ont trouvé qu'ils étaient très abondants et très divers
dans l'écosystème de l'océan.
Ils sont particulièrement abondants dans ce qu'on appelle
les tourbillons océaniques.
Ceux-ci sont parfois cités comme étant les déserts des océans,
mais ce ne sont pas du tout des déserts.
En profondeur, cela grouille
de centaines de millions de cellules de Prochlorococcus par litre.
Si on les rassemblait comme nous le faisons dans nos cultures,
on pourrait voir le beau vert de leur chlorophylle.
Un seul de ces tubes à essai contient un milliard de Prochlorococcus
et, comme je vous l'ai dit précédemment,
il y en a trois milliards de milliards de milliards sur la planète.
Cela fait trois octillions,
si vous vous donnez la peine de faire la conversion.
(Rires)
Et, tous ensemble, ils pèsent plus lourd que la population humaine
et ils photosynthétisent autant que toutes les cultures sur terre.
Elles sont incroyablement importantes dans les océans mondiaux.
Après des années d'étude,
en découvrant à quel point elles étaient abondantes,
on s'est posé une question :
Comment une seule espèce peut-elle être si abondante dans des habitats si divers ?
En en isolant plus en culture,
on a découvert qu'elles avaient des écotypes différents.
Certaines se sont adaptées aux intensités lumineuses élevées
dans l'eau de surface
et d'autres se sont adaptées à la faible intensité lumineuse au fond de l'océan.
En fait, ces cellules qui vivent au fond de la zone ensoleillée
sont les photosynthétiseurs les plus efficaces
de toutes les cellules connues.
Puis on a découvert qu'il y a certaines souches
qui se développent de manière optimale le long de l'équateur
où les températures sont plus élevées
et d'autres dans des températures plus fraiches, en allant du Nord ou au Sud.
Au fil des recherches, nous découvrions de plus en plus de diversité
et nous pensions : « Oh mon Dieu, ils sont si différents ! »
C'est à ce moment qu'il est devenu possible de séquencer leur génome
et de voir leur composition génétique.
Nous avons pu séquencer le génome des cultures que nous avions
et récemment, à l'aide de la cytométrie de flux,
nous pouvons isoler les cellules individuelles de la nature
et séquencer leur génome un par un
et nous avons séquencé des centaines de Prochlorococcus.
Et bien que chaque cellule possède à peu près 2 000 gènes --
c'est un dixième de la taille d'un génome humain --
et plus on en séquence,
plus on découvre qu'ils n'ont qu'un millier de ceux-ci en commun
et que l'autre millier est particulier à chaque souche
est tiré d'un énorme pool de gènes
et cela reflète l'environnement particulier où les cellules ont prospéré,
pas seulement l'intensité de la lumière ou la température,
mais s'il y a des nutriments qui les limitent
comme l'azote, le phosphore ou le fer.
Cela reflète l'habitat duquel elles sont issues.
Pensez-y comme ça.
Si chaque cellule est un smartphone
et les applications les gènes,
en achetant un smartphone, il y a des applications pré-installées.
On ne peut pas les désinstaller.
Sur un Iphone, on appuie mais elles ne bougent pas
et elles n'ont pas de « x ».
Même si on n'en veut pas, on ne peut pas s'en débarrasser.
(Rires)
Celles-ci sont comme les gènes de base des Prochlorococcus.
Elles sont l'essence du téléphone.
Mais vous avez un énorme pool d'applications à utiliser
pour personnaliser votre téléphone selon votre mode de vie et votre habitat.
Si vous voyagez beaucoup, vous aurez des applications relatives au voyage,
si vous vous intéressez à la finance, vous aurez beaucoup d'applis liées,
ou si vous êtes comme moi,
vous avez plein d'applications sur la météo
espérant qu'une d'elles vous dira ce que vous voulez entendre.
(Rires)
J'ai appris en quelques jours à Vancouver
qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'app météo -- mais juste d'un parapluie.
Alors --
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Donc, tout comme votre smartphone révèle comment vous vivez,
votre mode de vie,
lire le génome d'une cellule de Prochlorococcus
nous en apprend sur les pressions qu'il connaît dans son environnement.
C'est comme de lire son journal intime,
ça nous dit non seulement comment s'est passée sa journée ou sa semaine,
mais aussi l'histoire de son évolution.
Au fur et à mesure -- nous avons classé des centaines de cellules
et maintenant nous pouvons conjecturer
la taille totale
du pool génétique
de la fédération du Prochlorococcus, comme nous pouvons l'appeler.
C'est comme un super-organisme.
Et il se trouve que les conjectures sont
que le collectif possède 80 000 gènes.
C'est quatre fois la taille du génome humain.
Et c'est cette diversité du pool de gènes
qui leur permet de dominer ces grandes étendues d'océan
et de maintenir la stabilité année après année.
Donc lorsque je rêve de Prochlorococcus,
ce que je fais probablement trop --
(Rires)
Je les imagine là, flottant, faisant leur travail,
maintenant la planète, nourrissant les animaux.
Mais je finis inévitablement par penser au chef d’œuvre qu'elles sont,
finement réglé par des millions d'années d'évolution.
Avec 2 000 gènes, ils peuvent faire ce que l'ingéniosité humaine
n'a pas encore réussi à faire encore.
Elles peuvent prendre l'énergie solaire, le CO2 et les transformer
en énergie chimique sous forme de carbone organique,
emprisonnant cette lumière solaire dans ces chaînes carbonées.
Si on pouvait exactement comprendre comment elles font,
cela pourrait inspirer des designs
qui pourraient réduire notre dépendance aux énergies fossiles,
ce qui boucle mon histoire.
Les énergies fossiles enterrées que nous brûlons
ont mis des millions d'années à être mises en terre,
y compris les ancêtres du Prochlorococcus
et maintenant, nous les brûlons en un clin d’œil
à l'échelle géologique.
Le taux de dioxyde de carbone augmente dans l'atmosphère.
C'est un gaz à effet de serre.
Les océans commencent à se réchauffer.
Alors la question est : « Quels effets cela va-t-il avoir
sur mon Prochlorococcus ? »
Vous pensez sûrement que je vais dire que c'en est fini pour mes microbes chéris
mais ce n'est pas le cas.
On prévoit une expansion des populations avec le réchauffement des océans
de 30% de plus d'ici l'an 2100.
Est-ce que ça me rend heureuse ?
Bien, je suis contente pour le Prochlorococcus, bien sûr --
(Rires)
mais pas pour la planète.
Il y a des gagnants et des perdants dans cette expérience globale
que nous avons entreprise
et il est prévu que, parmi les perdants,
il y ait certains phytoplanctons plus gros,
ceux qui sont charismatiques
qui, supposément, vont voir leur nombre diminuer
et ce sont eux qui nourrissent le zooplancton qui nourrit les poissons
que nous aimons pêcher.
Ainsi, le Prochlorococcus a été ma muse durant les dernières 35 années
mais il y a des légions de microbes qui entretiennent la planète pour nous.
Ils sont là, quelque part,
prêts à être découverts pour pouvoir, eux aussi, raconter leur histoire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)